escape from Sudan after a perilous
Journey
arriving from West Darfur they say Arab
malicious set up checkpoints
searching for Rivals demanding payment
for safe Passage
chadian soldiers search for weapons a
final hurdle before Refuge from the war
we fled because we are looking for peace
there are problems over there they kill
you they take your belongings you want
to be in a place that's peaceful
Fatima is from elginina the city has
been in a state of siege for weeks
she says there is no water and nothing
to eat
she says nowhere is safe
at a hospital in Audrey the dangers to
civilians becomes clear
this man says dozens were killed his
village Mr Ray abandoned
all the soldiers went to fight in
Khartoum or Janina in our village we the
civilians were alone there is no
government to defend us for more than 20
years we've not had a government
even after Decades of this kind of
violence
it's indiscriminate nature can be
jarring
her son she says is too traumatized to
leave her side
this is the only General Hospital in
Audrey and administrators tell us there
are no more beds for the people that
keep coming the bulk of the patients
currently at this hospital around 75
percent are all Sudanese people who have
been fleeing the conflict in Darfur
the doctors here say they've never seen
so many bullet wounds
there is not enough staff enough
medicine
or enough power
they are doing what they can but not
everyone makes it
we received four bodies here Dead on
Arrival I remember one person who had a
bullet in their head one in the neck and
one in the heart
there were also two people that were
brought here whom we tried to stabilize
but unfortunately they passed away
inter-communal violence ethnic divisions
age-old rivalries pitting Arab tribes
versus non-airwoods the answers to why
there is violence in Darfur again are
many
but one point every Sudanese villager we
speak to seems to make
chaos comes in the absence of government
my hand my leg my belly all of these
were injured by a grenade
I have no news about what's happening
back there but we will not go back we
will stay here in chat because here
there is a government
she lost a finger and suffered injuries
to her head leg and foot but she and her
daughter made it out
as the violence in Darfur worsens
self-exile is the price for peace of
mind
and for survival
[Applause]
Zain Bas Ravi Al Jazeera Audrey Eastern
Chad